cuando empezó la pandemia del cob y
éstas eran algunas de las huellas que
las protestas de octubre dejaron en las
paredes de santiago hoy estos muros han
sido limpiados entre ellos las obras de
callo chama uno de los artistas visuales
más conocidos durante la revuelta
aquí y aquí ya está todo el día de
llegar hasta acá
y ahora ya como ven no hay nada por
todos todos los mensajes hay ocultos
atrás de esto esta capa de pintura
es parte de todo lo que nos borraron a
todos los artistas
en hamacas al frente de un lado está
todo gris el gobierno chileno
aprovecho la pandemia para borrar los
símbolos del estallido social restaurar
el mobiliario de plaza italia el lugar
emblemático de las manifestaciones y
poner una guardia durante 24 horas en
los monumentos que habían sido tomados
en el congreso avanza un proyecto la ley
stickers que sancionará con multas y
penas de cárcel a las personas que
pongan pegatinas en el mobiliario
público o transporte entre otros y que
podría hacer que calles como esta ya no
se vean más evidentemente en un ataque a
una de las expresiones más sencillas y
cotidianas justamente de la protesta de
lo que significa el expresarse y el
expuesto a ciertas ideas en un
transporte que además es público además
el gobierno envió un proyecto de ley
para regular la cooperación con la corte
penal internacional haciendo cambios que
podrían implicar el blindaje del
ejecutivo ante las posibles
responsabilidades por las violaciones de
derechos humanos ocurridas el 18 de
octubre para los artistas la lucha sigue
y para calles llama no hay arma más
poderosa que su arte ya me lo tomé muy a
pecho de comunicar de mostrar lo que
está pasando y esta es mi manera de
hacerlo y si me dice medianamente preso
me van a multar y todo bueno tendré que
que asumir las consecuencias pero voy a
seguir igual que igual que siempre y
creo que todos los artistas que estamos
en esto pensamos igual y como muestra
[Aplausos]